hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well mentor in this
piece is starting out from what he calls
a natural law perspective yeah we're
only gonna get to that at the very end
of the semester to go into detail but
here's some of the stuff in a nutshell
according to the natural law perspective
we have certain inclinations can woven
into the fabric of our being by being
human beings certain tendencies to value
to desire to to pursue certain Goods and
these can get mixed up and these can go
astray you know so you know having
security is a good you know when you
actually have what a security security
is the ability to hold on to other goods
to keep them safe things that are
recognized as values do people go the
wrong way with that sometimes yeah
sometimes people think money translates
into security so there's not make a ton
of money and put everything along until
then and then they get you know get it's
on the money and they realized oh hey I
went astray I passed up all these other
goods you can sacrifice them to it yeah
but we do have these basic inclinations
and they're connected to goods things
that we perceive as good
desire that we want to hold on to that
hopefully we want other people to have
we're not told your selfish rules are
also an important part of our normal
life - right when you were a kid you
probably thought that being a good kid
yeah it's something or mainly to do with
with rules right and even now think
about you know for example your Student
Conduct code how is that this very long
document if any of you read through the
whole thing you yeah good job yeah it's
pretty comprehensive and it's a range in
terms of rules isn't it now rules can't
cover everything eventually to develop
in in moral life
we need traits of character that allow
us to figure out when the rules should
apply where they shouldn't I think about
the discretion that's needed to be a
good RA there are some areas that are
terrible are aids because they they know
the rules inside and out and they
applied them in every single case just
as rigidly and that's not actually
achieving the goods that at the Dinaric
is supposed to achieve when are they
supposed to keep order you know help
cultivate students that sort of thing
instead of stifling which could be the
result so there's certain virtues
certain character traits that we need to
develop these are all part of what
MacIntyre calls a moral scheme so every
moral theory tells you something about
what are the goods it tells you about
how these Goods should be arranged in
order in relation to each other it gives
you some rules about how you should go
about doing things how these goods ought
to be attained or protected or chosen or
sacrificed and it also tells you what
kind of a person you ought to be and
what kind of person you don't want to be
there's there's another term that is
correlated to virtue that we use in
moral theories convice when somebody has
advice that's a bad character trait we
often think of it in terms
you're drinking or prostitution or stuff
like that that's because we've come to
use the word vice in a very narrow way
smoking may not even actually be of us
drinking isn't for the ancient you know
philosophical guise of drinking by
itself is not advice
drinking too much in and out of
controlled manner that's applies usually
an expression of gluttony now Amanda
Turner also talks about practices and I
want you to think for a minute just
about all the different things that you
do and have done in your life that would
fall under the rubric of what he calls
practices and what he means by that our
activities in which there are some Goods
internal to that activity that are
achieved through the activity so for
instance being an RA would be being a
practice you know helping to you know
you can break it into sub practices
keeping order or counseling people being
an EMT would be another practice being
our sports team would be the practice
new practices of course but you know not
not methods because there are certain
goods that are attained within their
goods that might be able to be attained
in other ways but are definitely a team
that way you know if you if you want to
get good at a sport you have to actually
do drills right and how many of you have
played on the sports not necessarily
here at Marist but in a high school or
middle school
almost all of it so all of you remember
doing boring drills right whether it's
for basketball or soccer or volleyball
and when you first did the drill did you
know the reason for doing them and why
did you do it
coach said so right there was an
authority figure saying get over there
then if you didn't do it right go run
some laps or maybe they they're nicer to
you guys
maybe I'll at us a lot we didn't really
understand why the elbows and then after
a while if you do the drill and you're
not just even like going through the
motions but you actually do what you're
supposed to do you don't understand why
you're doing that did you hope did you
hopefully come to that point where
suddenly you have a new skill at your
disposal and you were able to see oh
that was the point of this did you have
that experience that's what that's a
good in the end of practice might be a
small gun and I like being able to steal
the ball from somebody being able to set
you know pick right things like that or
it might be something pretty big but
there's a lot of that that goes on
within within practices so McIntyre
talks about these as Norman formed
activities he says we discover ourselves
as being an enormous Ords goals which
are recognized as goods and in the case
of doing practices and this is what
Thomas Aquinas was talking about this
was an aerosol was talking about but you
haven't read those guys yet so you know
you just have to take it on faith that
this is actually what you're talking
about so he says I have these
inclinations but I can I can realize
they have and I discover that my wife is
partially ordered by regularities which
give expression to these primary
tendencies towards particular habits
like say for example having friends or
you know feeling pleasure that's an end
that you know brings you toward it so I
have in my power to make these ends mine
in a new and secondary way by
consciously directing my activities
these ends and insofar as I correctly
understood my own nature it would be
rash
for me to do so what was mere regularity
becomes rule governess this is where we
start to get some of the rules by which
we worry into our life from you know and
think about some of the rules that
people have that you know steer them
right and then some of the ones that
steer than wrong have some bad
experiences I shouldn't trust anybody
that's a rule and somebody may actually
follow that rule and if they are doing
it they consider that to be rational
that's why some people become very
closed off and guarded right anyway he
says there's two distinctive ways we may
have an end we can have it in because
it's sort of built into our framework
and then he says its inner power whether
or not in a rational decision making
whether we direct our activities towards
the achievements of them so we can move
in different directions we we have a
capacity at different points to actually
say I'm going to do something
differently I asked you earlier you have
you ever had the experience of saying
I've screwed up my priorities I need to
change when you did that you actually
made a rational decision to redirect
yourself towards Mother Abbess
I let my friendship slide I shouldn't
have done that it should have been less
focused on my career and more on the
people who matter in my life that would
be rational decision-making right there
so he says usually how do we do this we
achieve this through involvement in
activities which raise for individuals
the question what is my good in a manner
that's complementary to that in which
the question is posed by in with the
nation's type of activity characteristic
of what he's calling them practices and
he gives you some examples of these
activities as members of string quartets
you know how many of you play music
closer
how many played a musical instrument can
be and/or inquire
so that does everybody gets to do
whatever they want if you're in a group
when you're warming up how's that sound
Tara right what is it like when you
actually coordinate your activities with
live people it's kind of fun playing on
your own you know but then you actually
have other people to play with and
things are coming together there are
certain goods that you cannot attain
solely on your own out there now of
course you know you can get yourself a
karaoke machine it's not quite the same
back and working with there's certain
goods that are attained in them he talks
about the crews of fishing fleets
McIntyre always loves that example
architects and construction workers
joined the engage and developing good
housing members of families making and
sustaining their familiar community
they're familiar familial community
farmers and physicists these are all
practice structuring sets in order to do
these rights so that the goods internal
to the practice are generated you can't
do things any old way that you want to
so you come to experience the fact that
you have to subordinate your own desires
for a while to do this the things that
don't originally make sense to you but
will come to make sense as rules the
coach tells you go do the drills you go
and do the drills doesn't doesn't do
anything for you the first day but after
a couple of weeks of that suddenly
you're able to function as a team member
right you do all the boring scales at
your music teacher has
those of you who have done you know
music you know a lot of morning
exercises and arpeggios come next or
that other things like that and what
happens eventually there's a point where
you're able to attain that good in there
and if you decide for yourself I'm not
doing this this boring scale around I
didn't want to play songs will you
actually place on us no what have you
you're gonna go on the soccer team I'm
just gonna play soccer I've got a native
talent for it and I'm just gonna go out
there and play how does that work when
your teammates are actually doing drills
and practicing together and stuff like
that you're not going to attain the
goods involving them it's that way for a
lot of activities and so we come to
understand that there's we can't do
everything that we want we have to be
governed by rules and those those rules
may help us to make some distinctions
and he talks about two important
distinctions one of these is that he
says between what I would do if I did
what would please me most here and now
and what I would do if in the light of
the best instruction available to me I
were to do what would make me excellent
in the pursuit of the goods it's a big
mouth so let's boil it down what would
what would make me happy right now what
will make me happier when I attain those
goods you guys have made that
distinction before in your life right
otherwise you couldn't be here in this
classroom what will make me immediately
happy what will actually make me happy
what appears to be able to be happiness
what is actually that's something that
you have to be able to do if you can't
do that you can't be actually attained a
lot of goods so the second distinction
is that between what it would be to
achieve what's good and best
unqualifiedly and what is good and best
here and now for me
so there's have you ever heard the
expression don't let the best become the
enemy of the good you guys know that
expression a lot of times you can't
attain the best this is what leads
people to procrastination and to never
ending things that my paper isn't as
good as it could be so I can't hand it
in it's a good paper right but it's not
as good as it could be it's not the best
and it never gets handed there that's
what that's letting the best become the
enemy of good this person who I'm
involved with you know I really like
them I really enjoy time with them they
provide me with all these goods in my
life that we share together but they
could be better looking they could be
you know well could be better and they
could you know fit into the scheme of my
interests a bit better so that's wedding
the best beyond the enemy of the good
McIntyre saying we have to learn how not
to do that now he also says we've got
this any of practices we don't live our
lives just within one practice hope
right we live in a life into the
matrices of practices and we come to
realize that there's some rules that we
need to follow across the board in order
to to have things go well for us so he
says you know if we if we think about
pursuing Goods and the company of other
rational persons there's some things
that we have to keep ourselves from
doing once we've made these distinctions
so he talks about
allegiance to particular rules and these
we have to proceed he says any set of
arguments and in theorizing they also
help us to lead to virtues because how
do we come to think about good character
traits something like being courageous
being honest being fair at first we're
given rules right don't take more than
your fair share
that's about what being being courageous
what is it about being fair being what
in traditional theory we call being just
and you have to give kids these we says
we learn to be courageous or temperate
or truthful my first learning that
certain types of action are always an
exceptional such as we must refrain from
we're doing exemplify those virtues
now our rules enough for us I think you
guys have come to the point in your life
you realize know that no one single set
of rules is ever going to cover
everything you have to develop what we
call breeze at least from Asus I think
really good translation for us is being
able to tell when to apply the rules how
to apply the rules when the rules
actually intersect with each other when
they can flick with each other we also
have to develop other virtues it doesn't
do much good to be a rule follower if
you're actually a coward if you're
gutless as we say it doesn't do much
good to be a rule follower if you
haven't acquired a disposition towards
truthfulness or towards justice McIntyre
would say so he says learning these
virtues in a wide range of difficult
different situations is inseparable from
learning which out of the multiplicity
of goods are at stake so you see all
three of these are connected with each
other
in certain ways now this is a very
Aristotelian or Thomas account of virtue
ethics or natural law count of how good
rules and virtues are connected together
he says that these can be fragmented in
the plan person's own
and that is in fact the case for many
plane curses